president Trump disinvited the Super
Bowl champion Philadelphia Eagles to
visit the White House and he did this
when he found out most the team wouldn't
be coming so to sort of get ahead of it
he disinvited them now this is becoming
a bit of an embarrassment for the
president because there are a lot of
athletes out there refusing to visit our
controversial commander-in-chief
so last night as a service to our
president we put together a list of all
the athletes who are still willing to
meet with President Trump yes and today
we wanted to update the list so here are
some more sports figures who would say
yes if they were invited to the White
House they include the Tampa Bay water
polo champions we'll go yeah amateur
highlights Shanna cork oohs and graz
said he'll go
Indiana University full court putt
Challenge winner Pat Barnes says he'll
go the commissar of three-card Monte mr.
Fontaine will go
eight-time cockfight champ Attila the
hen
and of course Tonya Harding Lance
Armstrong Pete Rose and Oscar Pistorius
all very much
[Applause]
you